like cloud-based cameras and we all
floated like was it a hack like the fact
no no apparently they're saying that uh
I guess Candace said it was the wife it
was yeah that's the simplest explanation
but I'm just anti-amazon ring cameras
and I feel like this is a good moment to
put that in there yeah I just all the
way when someone is on camera and
they're like Phil that time you struck
me was wrong and then you're like what
are you talking about don't deny it now
you're proving it and then I and then
the footage gets released and it's like
oh wow look at this Phil looks really
really bad I'm just kind of like you
know she walks up to him and she says
he's abusing her and then gives the
footage to someone it's kind of like